[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello.
My name is Alan Feder.
And I'm a Principal Data
Scientist at Invesco.
My talk today is about
categorical embeddings
in the embed
package in R. If you
are trying to create
a predictive model,
you'd really like to use all of
the variables in your data set,
as that's what's
likely to create
the most accurate and
successful predictions.
But you may soon
run into a problem
because many of the
functions within R,
that are used to
create these models
require that all of the input
data are continuous numbers.
Now this makes sense because
many of the computations that
go on in the background work
on linear algebra and matrices,
which inherently can only
have numbers in them.
But that might be a problem for
you because some of your data
may be categorical
variables and you don't
want to have to drop them.
You might try to replace
each category with a number--
1, 2, 3, which might work
if your data is ordinal.
But if your data doesn't have
any inherent order to it,
this might not work.
If one of your
categories is color,
how are you going
to choose numbers
for black, brown,
yellow or green.
You might try to
create dummy variables
but this actually can cause
big data problems really quick.
Dummy variables will
create a new variable
for each level of your data.
And for example, if
one of your categories
is United States
zip code, you're
about to add 42,000 new
variables to your data
and that's probably
not what you want.
That leads me to
categorical embeddings.
If you're familiar with Word
embeddings, such as Word2Vec.
This is actually a very
similar idea except instead
of an embedding for
each Word in language,
you're embedding each
category in your data.
What happens is that
every category is replaced
by a vector of numbers.
The vector can be length, 4
can be length, 15-- it really
depends on the situation.
But these numbers will replace
your categorical variable
for any future modeling.
Now categorical variables
are most commonly
fit by neural networks, which is
why within R many of the most
common ways of
creating them are using
the keras or tenserflow
for packages or the new torch
package.
However, I find the
simplest way to do
it is with the
embed package, which
is one of the add-on
packages in a tidymodel's
suite of packages.
For example, let's say you had
a data set of sales transactions
and you wanted to predict, which
transactions are fraudulent
and which ones are not.
Having product in
there, you can imagine
how that would help the
predictive ability of the model
but with over 4,500
unique products, that's
going to cause problems
with creating your model.
But with the embed
package, all you have to do
is add one function step embed
onto a tidymodel's recipe
to create this embedding.
Once you've prepped this
recipe, the embeddings
are there for use.
And you can see here
how each product is now
represented by an
embedding of four numbers.
And these four numbers are
going to replace the old product
category within the
data going forward.
You can now use this for
any downstream model.
It doesn't even have
to be a neural network.
You could also use
this if you wanted just
to explore your data further and
learn more about the products.
Maybe you could use
cosine similarity
to figure out which products
are most similar to each other.
Now there's obviously a ton
more that I could talk about
with categorical embeddings.
It's a topic that I
find really exciting.
I hope you learned
and discover more
about categorical
embeddings, as you use them
within your modeling.
Thank you very much for
coming and good luck.